Richard you still think Kansas City is
going to win I mean you're hoping
they're going to win but I think the
Eagles are the better team no no which
quarterback has been in the Super Bowl
before my home a home he has experience
that's huge what are they saying about
that high ankle sprain I think he's had
enough rest on it he did fine at the AFC
Championship game it was only one week
right yeah the Eagles defensive line is
huge and they are going to land on that
leg repeatedly uh Wolfie you're wearing
your full Eagles
um helmet and Jersey I'm [__] ready
Howard the Chiefs are going to lose Andy
Reid is a choke artist they're not going
to win punch yourself in that helmet
puts on a football helmet he does look
like he's gonna bang his head into a
wall when Wolfie comes on and he goes
I'm ready and you realize what he's
ready for he's ready to watch TV he
looks like an idiot Andy Reid was the
coach of the Eagles for a very long time
and I'm he loved him as the coach then
but now he's on Kansas City and all of a
sudden he can't stand Annie
14 years in a row it didn't get us a
Super Bowl like right he's a loser but
now you're jealous because he got the
chiefs of Super Bowl we got a Super Bowl
we got our own without him right now
will Murray was talking about a bet
where if the Eagles win I have to wipe
his ass with one of my Chiefs jerseys if
the Chiefs win he has to wipe my ass
with one of his Eagles jerseys I love
that bed I would that'd be great for the
air well you willing to do that were you
will you uh giant [__] right on that
stupid Kelsey Jersey
it's not gonna be my Kelsey Jersey
yes I don't know if I I can't bet I wore
this to the Super Bowl who sent us to
Howard what what Jersey do you care
about so much
he's gonna go get it if he gets it
is on I don't think Richard cares that
much look it's right there there's the
dog in his jersey it's like he doesn't
even wear it it's beautiful it's mint
conditioned all right you know what [__]
it I'll do it you know what because I
was just thinking I'll just wipe his
[__] off of my jersey I don't care of
course once since when do you care if
your jersey smells like [__] I thought I
get to [__] on this jersey I I mean no
to me if I gotta wipe his ass
yeah no that's the bet like I get oh wow
this is nice you wipe my ass with your
Eagles jersey okay that's fair I wipe
your ass with my Chiefs jersey okay all
right there you go what a bet go Birds
Go Chiefs
g l e s Eagles oh God
you know Wolfie sometimes I wish you'd
get this excited about work
[Laughter]